ils sont 20 à lever des fonds derrière
leur ordinateur
et pour ça il propose un direct à leur
public connectés sur twitch du jeu vidéo
de la danse
ou encore des activités comme ici un
atelier de survie il ya pas mal d
inégalités dans la société par rapport
aux femmes et je trouve ça super
important de se battre pour ça en fait
est de pouvoir défendre cette cause pour
la deuxième année consécutive
l'événement lève des fonds contre les
violences faites aux femmes
vous êtes là ça dort pas
l'occasion pour ces streamer d'interagir
avec leur communauté sur ce sujet
l'éducateur je travaille dans un foyer
avec des jeunes qui sont placés c'est
clairement le type d'intervention qu'on
pourrait avoir pour les jeunes dont je
m'occupe parce que nous des fois le la
parole que nous on peut apporter en tant
qu'éducateur eh ben elle va pas être
aussi importantes que des personnes de
l'extérieur les spectateurs randonnée
12700 euros l'an dernier
pourtant les organisateurs ont eu du mal
encore cette année à trouver des
partenaires intéressés par le projet
c'est en fait un événement où on parle
de streaming parle de jeux vidéo et
c'est vrai que peut-être il ya pas mal
dassault qui sont pas forcément informés
là dessus
donc du coup voilà s'il faut trouver une
association qui a au moins une appétence
un peu informatique réseaux sociaux est
aussi qui bat comme nous le crij qui
parle aussi aux jeunes c'est finalement
l'association raisonnante qui a répondu
à l'appel et elle ne regrette pas on
venait vraiment sans savoir à quoi
s'attendre et c'était surtout pour
diffuser nos outils tout simplement et
parler de cette thématique parce que
fixer notre public dans tous les cas
c'était intéressante pour eux d'avoir
ces informations là et là vraiment de
voir cette somme là
on n'espérait pas autant et on est hyper
heureux du résultat plus de 23000 euros
ont été récoltés en un peu plus de 24
heures aucun doute que birds of prey
aura droit à sa troisième édition